our attention span has dropped to five
seconds the sad news is the average
goldfish has 6 seconds we're now
competing with goldfish and the goldfish
are winning this was my bed right here
I had a bunk beds because sometimes
there'd be another guy working and this
was the toilet the bucket I bet you
could still they changed the floor there
was a hole in the floor in a bucket was
underneath you have to know what
motivates you and it's different for
different people you might not care
about cars
you know you might like travel or
freedom from a nine-to-five job
need motivation watch the top team we
believe nation what's up at 7:00 my one
word is believing I believe in you I
believe you have Michael Jordan level
talent adds something and I want you to
find it embrace it and use it to make a
difference so let's get your motivation
to attend and get you believing in you
grab a snack and chill in today's
lessons from a man who went from growing
up completely broke having to work on a
farm and live with the Amish to becoming
involved in over 20 multi-million dollar
businesses and having a successful
YouTube channel with 1.2 million
subscribers
he's Tai Lopez and here's my take on his
top ten roses success vol 3 joy
alright let's kick it off with rule
number one take some pain I started
Google AdWords in 2001 okay I was I got
lucky I just stumbled and I was one of
the first people to ever use online
advertising I was in I think the second
month Google AdWords launched and there
was no YouTube videos there was no Perry
Marshall books there was there was
nothing you just kind of wasted money to
learn now we're the most spoiled
generation everything this computer on
this phone iPhone 7 is more powerful
than the first rocket that put man on
the moon that cost billions of dollars
now we get that for under a thousand
bucks and people are still like on lost
yes your loss sit down and then open up
Safari and go how to do Google ads and
you're gonna come up let's see what I
come up with Adwords they have their own
tutorial word stream jump if I you got
some paid stuff then you have some free
stuff on HubSpot if you sit in a chair
Charlie Munger calls it assiduity put
your ass in a chair sit there and focus
without being you know the average
American right now the average first in
the world our attention span has dropped
to five seconds the sad news is the
average goldfish has 6 seconds we're now
competing with goldfish and the goldfish
are winning so if you don't have
assiduity to sit down breed there is no
solution for you you will always be poor
because you'll always be beat by
somebody who's willing to sit in the
chair is there a way for people to build
that discipline yes pain and that's why
I'm not a big believer in delusion you
know you asked me one of the rewiring
things we have to do in this world I'll
tell you one you ever heard this myth
everything happens for a reason so just
accept it well there's kind of truth to
that if I jump off a building and break
my legs
yes everything happened for a reason the
reason was gravity like that's why you
break your legs and physics legs brittle
concrete not brittle so that but people
interpret everything happens for a
reason be like well
I was meant to learn from that thing and
then BS read Richard Dawkins The Selfish
Gene one of the most important books
written in the last century
he says organisms that only learn
through trial and error lose to
organisms that can learn through other
people's a trial and error is anybody
here we got a little live audience
anybody here ever had to be hit by a car
to learn to look both ways I did it I
kind of learned from just somebody
telling me big car two tons velocity
smash dead and I now always look both
ways so if you're myth is that the only
way you're gonna learn is just through
massive mistakes in trial and error you
have a read Richards talking book how
does pain allow somebody to get more
disciplined okay so going back to that
myth of when you see your life and
anytime there should be pain you go no
no no no it was just how it was meant to
be
no look yourself in the mirror sometimes
and go you know why I'm not happy it's
because I didn't listen ten years ago
and I got in the wrong career you know
I'm not happy because I married the
wrong damn person it wasn't meant to
happen yes everything happens for a
reason you made a bad choice but it
didn't have to be that way and the
second you build up pain and this by the
way is not my opinion if you talk to
guys like dr. David buss top ten most
cited psychologist in history okay he's
one of my main mentors he told me I said
to adults change like we do all this
self-help videos and podcasts I said I'm
not wasting my time he goes yeah kind of
I said why he said well after twenty
five it's very hard to teach old dogs
new tricks by the way that's why I've
changed most of my stuff targets people
18 to 25 that's why I do snapchat and
all that because there's hope for 18 to
25 well now if you're over 25 before you
get depressed he told me but I have good
news for you time I said what he said
adults learn through massive trauma so
you will learn you have to let in some
trauma into your life in that
ruff but no pain no gain like if you are
a hundred pounds overweight and you want
to be able to play basketball here's my
news for you everything happened for a
reason you got fat cause you ate too
much and you didn't exercise so welcome
to the gym and the first year is gonna
be hell but that pain hopefully will
reprogram your brain at every time you
want to eat that nasty thing go wait I
don't want to go through that pinion so
I think one of the myths of societies we
won't let pain in we just excuse it all
away like nah that wasn't meant to
happen
oh you wasted 20 years of life married
the wrong person in the wrong career no
Tom it was meant to happen where's the
people who go you you wasted 20 years
and you will never get it back you
better go in your room and cry and the
truth is you only learn as an adult
unfortunately most people can only
change with massive trauma rule number 2
hustle I want to show you what it means
to give sweat equity that if you don't
have any money start with sweat equity
meaning go work for somebody else use
your time energy to make them money
that's what I did I'm here at Joel
Salatin my first mentors farm and he
said if you want to work for me you can
live in this little cabin and it didn't
have a toilet what had a bucket so and
it had no heat or no water
this was my bed right here I had a bunk
beds because sometimes there'd be
another guy working and this was the
toilet the bucket I bet you can still
they change the floor there was a hole
on the floor and a bucket was underneath
nightstand here I put a cup of water in
it to drink and we sleep in sleeping
bags and when I woke up it was a always
an ice ice that's how you know it's cold
in the morning you reach over like the
hole tingles the truth you can't start
out at the top you start out at the
bottom how the game goes the natural
order of things
rule number three have a map of success
the third thing that you got to know is
you have to have a map of success so
think about you know the olden days age
to bury treasure and to find it they
would have a map and if you didn't have
that map you could spend all the hard
work all the time all the
effort all the labor you wanted you
never would find the treasure and the
school system failed us let's just face
it elementary school junior high high
school I'm not saying all schools bad
but I'm saying there's things that
didn't teach us we didn't learn the
proper tools and so we weren't given the
map to success and that's why so many
people are in debt and why so many
people are depressed and why so many
people have financial trouble and so
many people don't know how to invest
their money it comes from a lack of a
map and I want to give you a map and
that's part of why I've traveled to 40
or 50 countries once I was sleeping on
that couch I found a mentor Mike
Stainback one thing led to another I
began Business Network and beginning to
travel I've been to you know New Zealand
Japan and South America Bolivia Chile
Germany all these countries around the
world where I found mentors who gave me
a map they said here ty here's what
worked for us I remember being in
Germany with a guy who invited me and
and he was you know 30 years older than
me and he laid out how he just told me
we went on up walk back to the hotel
where I was staying I was speaking doing
a little business talk there to his
staff and he said I want to share with
you what worked for me I started at 12
years old and now I'm 70 years old and I
want to show you what worked for me Ty
and I remember thinking this guy's
giving me the map what if they had given
me that map when I was 18 years old in
school life would have been so much
easier if you have the map you'll cut
the learning curve rule number four
operate from a sense of logic and duty
if you have a concept called never be
the [ __ ] of your own mind yes what do
you mean by that
your mind is driven by deep evolutionary
drives so for example narcissism is a
protection mechanism right so your mind
wants to tell you you're amazing it
makes you its [ __ ] you have to override
that and go you know what I'm not that
amazing so let me go learn from amazing
people do you have methods for people to
do that because I think that's so
important so I tell people don't trust
everything that your mind says surveys
don't
by into all of your emotions just
because you have an emotion doesn't mean
you have to act in accordance with that
but how do you help people get over that
how do they overcome that I think humans
for the most part learn by osmosis so
it's hard to lecture people into success
but what you could do is you could
inspire people to understand this so for
example if you could if school system
could find all the 14 year olds and find
out what they admire in people right
it's the reason I showed Lamborghinis
Ferraris so I got a lot of young
followers and you know what 19 year old
guys like Lamborghinis and Ferraris so I
show that part of my life because then
they listen to the other stuff so first
you got to lead by inspiration this has
been proven over you cannot pound stuff
into people's brain people actually do
the opposite when parents tell their
kids you've got to read nobody reads but
if I show a Lamborghini and Ferrari
which is the reward that people want and
then people go how do you get it I said
see all these books I read them and put
it then people I have more school kids
reading books I think than anyone in
history I don't say that cocky I'm
telling you it astounds me because all I
had to do was put up a video with
Lamborghinis right and so being the
[ __ ] of your own brain the way you
learn not to be the easiest way is to be
around people who aren't the [ __ ] of
their own brain like Joel Salatin my
first mentor I was lucky enough right
out of high school instead of going to
college I was with him at 19 and he is
not a [ __ ] of his brain he's a man of
he wakes up and his life's more like of
duty he knows his duty and whether it's
hard or easy he plows through it so
everyday for example when he had
breakfast at 6:00 in the morning on a
farm he writes out an organized thing on
what he wants to do for the day when
you're the [ __ ] of your brain you go
I'm just gonna freewheel this day it's
very it's very hard to be organized
we're not dogs aren't organized you ever
see your dog organizing day so if you
want to you can either act on the animal
side which is just a wing life or you
can operate from a sense of logic and
duty and so I learned somewhat I'm not
even as good as Joel to not be the [ __ ]
my mind by just being around for
and so that's the best way find somebody
that you look at them and you go this is
a person of discipline a motivation self
motivation they don't need external
motivation they're motivated from within
and spend all the time you can around
ruler five focus look the reason I talk
about social is it gives you something
to focus on but let me step back so many
you can't focus because let's just face
it you know social media makes money by
making you unfocused scientists have
studied how Facebook Instagram Twitter
all of these apps have created
addictions and that's how why the people
who own them are the richest people in
the world now I use social media so I'm
not gonna say don't use social media
Hill practical tip for 2018 turn off all
notifications on my phone I don't have
one notification on so if you have an
iPhone go to settings right here go
scroll down and notifications where's my
notifications right there turn
everything off look at mine show
previews never off uh-uh-uh-uh-uh
every single one is off okay because I'm
not a sucker I use social media but
social media is not gonna use me I look
at my facebook when I want to not what
Mark Zuckerberg wants me to dopamine is
released by these apps it's literal
physical addictions created by these
again you can use social media but don't
let it use you so just a little
practical thing turn off the damn social
media notifications Instagram won't be
there you got to be reminded every time
someone deems you why are you too dumb
that you can't remember that Instagram a
notification if you can't remember it
that means it's probably not important
so he's a win-win situation you got more
time and less distraction so focus in
2018 I gave you the first thing to focus
on which is your social life you're
gonna have to focus you know I I don't
know how
draw a horse very well but I'll just use
a square with a head every time I try to
draw people were like you're horrible at
drawing so I am horrible so horse I used
to have a horse and they put these
things on the side of horses right here
they're called blinders they don't
really blind the horse but they the
horse can only see straight ahead and
the reason they do that is because when
you're out on the road with a horse I
live with the Amish for two years if a
call big car comes by and the horse sees
that out of the corner of their eye they
get scared and I actually knew a guy
that he was driving along the side of a
road there was a cliff on the edge that
he didn't put the blinders on that horse
to focus the horse a big truck was
coming the horse saw and kind of went
like that inside boo no he didn't die
but he want to run off the cliff got
injured got thrown off three four five
six months rehabilitating from their
injury that's a good metaphor for people
you need to put your blinders on and
focus straight ahead for 2018 what do
you want out of 2018 more money more
happiness more time more freedom focus
that brain on that thing you can't be
this is the average person's brain in
one second
they want to focus on let's say they're
trying to improve their business well
they also think about oh I've got a DM
oh okay snapchat my mom's calling me oh
I wonder if you know what happened next
Game of Thrones episode focus it can be
as simple as for example make a time
when you check all your social media I
do it I try to check it once a day now
I'm in the business of social media so I
do check a little more but my personal
side try to wake up focus and I just go
through all my half one by one and get
it out of way fifteen minutes you know I
I have a lot of social media followers
so it sometimes takes me a little longer
I got thirteen million or something so I
get a lot of DMS but still I'm not gonna
check them all be real why just because
you know so if you got a thousand or two
thousand followers whatever five
thousand I used to have a hundred
followers it took me ten seconds a day
and then I don't need to
check out the average person at work is
checking their email they said like 20
to 50 times an hour
little waste the life man don't waste
your life rule number 6 find motivation
you have to know what motivates you and
it's different for different people you
might not care about cars
you know you might like travel or
freedom from a nine-to-five job whatever
your thing is find out your mix I wish
the school system had taught us this you
know we learned so many things that we
don't need in school you learn isosceles
triangles in the history of Mesopotamia
but what about how to be productive
overcome procrastination figure out what
motivates you for me it's a mix of a
little bit of materialistic things some
non materialistic things like freedom
and travel ability to help other people
help my family help charities that mix
gets me out of bed every day and you got
to know yours rule number seven let fear
Drive you there's this test called the
dark triad test which again anything
important like this nobody ever learned
it in school because schools are too
stupid to take real powerful science and
apply it to life but the dark triad is a
worldview barometer for everybody
watching you can take it there's a
different dark free dark triad tests
online it tests for three main traits
negative qualities narcissism
Machiavellianism and being psychotic and
I've personally tested thousands and
thousands of people it's the most
accurate test and what happens
narcissism okay one of the symptoms of a
narcissist it's not just like oh I like
to look in the mirror right that's what
we think of Marcy one of the classic
symptoms is very thin-skinned
they're always offended if you have a
friend that anything you say
constructively they fall apart it's
almost always narcissism even if they're
introverted there's multiple forms
there's introverted narcissism
extroverted exploitative all these
different sub facets of narcissism but
we live in a society that's very
narcissistic you're told like everybody
is a winner
no not everybody's a winner that's like
saying everybody's blonde there's a
definition of what blonde is blonde is
like this yellowish air so you lose
meaning when you start going and
everybody's blonde
well everybody doesn't win and the
sooner
you wake up to that that biology is
ruthless man then you get a little fear
in you and when you get a little fear in
you you start listening because if
you're truly afraid you listen let a
little fear come in and drive you in
motivate you rule number eight don't get
stuck in the financial matrix at the
house here a Warren Buffett one of the
richest billionaires in the world he
bought this house in 1958 one of the
reasons most people call financial
matrix is they don't teach you in school
you should invest in things that don't
appreciate you know so he does have a
house and houses real estate so it's
somewhat good investment but most of he
makes 200 billion dollars a year cash
flow not all net but he makes that
investing in businesses he does some
real estate that's what you got to do or
else like I said people trapped in the
financial matrix the financial matrix is
basically where you work for somebody
and you never break free so you're like
this slave and so you have to have
create excess cash you got to create
investments that work for you while you
sleep while he's sleeping in this house
that he bought in 1958 for probably I
don't know a hundred grand
he's his businesses are generating you
know 20 billion dollars a year form up
for them and you can replicate that on a
small scale you don't have to do 20
billion but you have to learn how to
self educate yourself don't get stuck in
the financial matrix rule number nine
learn from people one of the things
that'll change our life or the thing
that changes your life people ask me is
it a book that you read is that people
go I want to become an investor in
general what changes your life there's a
good book on this by Jim Collins one of
the top business writers it's luck
events of who you meet so I go to I went
to that Omaha Nebraska investor meeting
because by being around other investors
I deal in person but when you can't do
it in person it could be through a book
or through a video that's what teaches
you how to become an investor it's not
like life's not just all about facts
like okay you invest in real estate or
you invest the stock market and
automatically you make money no it's
it's more sophisticated than that you
have to pick up from people their vibes
you have to pick up their habits their
intuition that's how you become a great
investor and rule number 10 the last
before a very special bonus clip is help
others my friend I'm gonna pay it
forward to today I got some money for
you what that's 500 bucks my friend make
sure you take care of your dog your dog
I'm gonna buy a van I swear to god
brother I'm getting off the streets your
dogs eating the shoe
you trying to get off the street today
yeah man what did you just say you said
there is a call I hope so what what's
your dog's name
whoa all right Scout you have a good day
now some people fry say he might use
that money for drugs and alcohol and
there's some truth to that but I don't
know at this point of my life I don't
feel like it's my place to judge
everything figure everything out just
try to help some people use it in the
right way some people abuse it but for
the people that do use it at least they
at least people didn't hold back giving
because of the people who do abuse it
you know what I mean
plus with that guy I kind of have a soft
spot for dog he's got his dog on make
sure his dog hopefully buy some dog food
vet bills you know feel like animals are
a lot of times helpless for all you that
are successful out there count your
blessings success and fame and money is
short but the good karma of giving to
other people hopefully lasts forever
help the helpless without too much
judgment
I wonder what the world would be like if
everybody all 7 billion people didn't go
to sleep until they did one random act
of kindness the interesting expert
probably better than all the nonsense
that goes on now in the world mileage
injustice what do I know until someone
figures out the answer I guess I'll keep
giving to the homeless and the helpless
I don't know I'm no saint but feels like
the right thing to do
I've got a really special bonus clip
from ty on how to get around people who
make you feel uncomfortable but before
that I want to know what did you learn
from this video
what nugget of wisdom that I drop on you
that you want to immediately apply
somehow to your life your business leave
in the comments below when you write it
down it's much more likely to stick that
you're actually gonna do it so leave it
in the comments thank you guys so much
for watching I believe in you I hope we
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is much love I'll
see you soon and enjoy the bonus clip
you know that old cliche it'd never be
the smartest person in the room and all
that it's I have a better way to say you
be around people who make you
uncomfortable at the ego level when you
feel uncomfortable in settings that is
when they learn it's not just who's
smarter because sometimes smarter people
don't help you there's many forms of IQ
there's emotional you know but get
around someone where you're like I kinda
don't fit in and because we're all
narcissists because of society and
Instagram and all this and I'm guilty of
that too we don't like to be
uncomfortable because a narcissist story
to themselves is you're the best and so
you know you your worldview is messed up
that's a wiring issue let me put it this
way I meet people who think they're
smart okay what it really tells me is
they've never been around actually smart
people if you're really smart watching
this let's say you have 155 IQ that's
what Bill Gates has in Albert Einstein
were up there my step grandfather had
155 IQ he speaks 14 language fluently he
can write Chinese he's a chess master he
can play three other chess masters
without looking at the board while they
look at the board and beat all them if
you're smart you can do that if you're
not I got good news for you Warren
Buffett says you only need about a 125
IQ to be very successful but it's better
to stay in your lane and just go I'm not
that smart but you can hire 155 IQs but
that's an example of what I'm talking
about of this rewiring and right so
these practical things will change your
life
[Music]
yeah the most important work ever if you
had to think of one word that's most
important to you or that sums you Apple
that would be to like a little beacon
pay believe nation if you want to know
what the most important one word is for
Tony Robbins Gary Vaynerchuk Oprah
Winfrey will.i.am and Howard Schultz I
have a very special secret video for you
check the description for details
[Music]